you just let me go position Sanchez over
Anana that's guaranteed Rees yeah 100%
100% Sanchez over Anana that's
guaranteed mate
Anana listen listen
[Music]
what there he ising what you saying you
good going on bro good good nice to see
you bro you
mate what we saying oh looking for
forward to this one December the 6th
yeah man not long now I've been telling
you I've been telling you Old Trafford
8:15 kickoff L you know what it's like I
think we come come over there and win
this time we ain't had a win there in a
while you know I'd rather have Marcio
Pino as my manager than Eric tenh 3 2
1 strongly wait hold on strongly is way
too far why would you rather have proo
the inen hog I think you look at what
pochettino's done so far at Chelsea I
would say he's developed a style of play
whether we're winning or not yet he's
developed a style of play that's
undeniable in games you can see that in
our bigger games this season when things
have gone our way a little bit more you
can definitely see that we're playing
some nice football with man united we're
what a year and a half into the project
now I don't know what they do po chatino
has got the got the thing on his side of
a lot of the signings haven't been his
signings so far 10 Hogs have been his
signings and again you look at the ones
he's bought in and for the most part the
big money spent it ain't gone down well
so I'm looking at the project now and
I'm thinking going forward who would I
rather have there I'd rather have
pochettino the difference between ten
hog and pochettino is ten hog gets
results poino is not getting results so
you can have the style of play which is
great we we need that style of play we
need a style of play we need an identity
but you got to get the results and poino
so far in his career he showed it at
Spurs he doesn't get over the line p PSG
he couldn't handle the big personalities
he didn't want to handle Neymar he
didn't want to handle Messi he didn't
want to handle mbappe and in the end he
ends up leaving out the back door yeah
he won a league arm but it wasn't it
didn't move them at all so so what you
see with portino is that he's a little
bit of a nearly man for me at least ten
hog gets results one a trop first season
far so far he you could say he's a
little bit of an if you want to be like
Spurs like the old Spurs end day what's
more impressive winning a couple of
leagues of Ajax or winning a league of
PSG well the answer is neither's that
impressive cuz it's a one horse race in
both of them leagues most of the time
right and then when you look at about
the personalities point 10 Hog's awful
with big personalities tell me a big
person tell me a big personality Ten's
done it well with every big personality
that has come into that club or been at
that club since ten Hog's been there
he's managed to somehow fall out with do
you think if we were give him 1 billion
1 billion to spend you don't think we'll
look better than Chelsea right now 10
ARS had more than portino 1 billion he's
no it's a billi it's a billion though he
knows what he was inheriting he knows
what the money ten hog spent since he's
come in he's spent way more than poas
but you know what you're inheriting this
is a this is a project that was passed
down from B you know what I'm trying to
say so he knows what he was inheriting
he inherited some good players he's
inheriting he's he's come through now
and he's getting enu he's getting Lavia
he's getting all these players these are
actual very good Ballers I think if
Manchester United were able to spend
that money in this short time 10 har has
had we will be in a better position
we're in a better position already but
we will be in a much better position we
wouldn't be hanging around loting around
10 Joey we would not be doing that let
me tell you that for free not be hanging
around T you're back in ten hog to be
able to spend money wisely where's the
track record what do you mean where's
the track record you look at the
signings at 10 Hogs B in so far you guys
love to talk everyone knows an he's a
flop yet but you love to talk aboutand
people go welland's not Hyland's not got
a goal yet but come on give him he's
doing all right in the Champions League
he looks a good player he looks a good
player he's yet to score a goal yeah I
think if Manchester United spent a
billion with a proper
structure under 10 hog we would not be
lering around 10th let me tell you that
you know that right it's but listen it's
fair it's fair but at the end of the day
not one person thought that when we
brought in AR Romeo Lavia when we
brought in even kaedo that's going to be
the piece of the puzzle where we push on
for the League this season 115 million
Chen no no no an a average average Squad
age if you take Thiago silv out 20 C I'm
not crazy no I'm not crazy I'm not
saying for the title but top four yeah
yeah listen you should not should be
you're B with brenford and Palace yeah
yeah come on man n this isn't this isn't
it nothing wrong with
Palace no Manchester United players
would make it into the Chelsea starting
11 3 2 1
come here come here see why do you what
there's not be strong be strong with
your chest there's not many yeah but the
question was no Manchester United player
was if you think even one should then
you strongly disagree no no no strongly
disagree yeah is if half the team make
it in if you only think one maybe two
make it in you just let me go position
Sanchez over Anana that's guaranteed
Reese Jack yeah 100% 100% Sanchez over
anana
that's guaranteed mate
Anana listen listen what Anana is
starting to come good in the last couple
of games how good is he coming or is
that a reflection of how poor he was the
jury's massively out on him for the for
this moment in time Sanchez over an Anor
for me yeah mate come on man look look
look look at the saves that Sanchez is
pulling off what I'm saying is Sanchez
of course is playing a poor side at the
moment yeah Sanchez is an average but a
he's average keep on yeah he is yeah
well you going say what's that saying he
is there you go Sanchez is average
agreed but Anana Anana is a little bit
worse than average for me let me let me
run for him you can tell me yeah right
back Reese James is he going to be fit
is going to be fit listen if everyone's
fit and available if we go strongest
center backs yeah you're one you're
going to give a shout out to is Martinez
Varan ain't I'm taking both of them
veran an agan Varan who's still younger
than Silva Silva's still better disagree
Silva's still better veran isn't getting
in your team over Harry mgu listen Eric
ten talk about his man management he
wants rid of Harry McGuire he wants
Harry McGuire to go to West Ham then all
of a sudden the Old Guard Harry MaGuire
jny Evans they start doing it for him
and he's having them back in Once Upon a
Time Rafa Benz tried to sell jabbi
Alonzo for Gareth Barry does doesn't
mean anything some managers are Co
cuckoo up there sometimes you know what
I mean they're mad they're mad I'm
taking veran I'm take hold on all right
let me see your team go on go so wait
you're taking who de sassy or something
no no no what you taking tago Silva Levi
i' have
Lev Silva over veran Martinez guys bring
water bring water this is ridiculous
what's you're take it so you're not
taking Leandro no you think L you think
Levi coell is better than Leandro
Martinez right now right you take them
both out of man United's team you put
them both into man City's team Levi C
starting ahead of him because you can't
go listen sometimes sometimes you can
have a player right that is elevated
massively as soon as they go into
another team we're talking about Chelsea
right now listen you can put bman that's
play for Chelsea that play for Man
United put him in city and pep will
Elevate their level so if I can take
Martinez to Chelsea I'm not playing him
I'm not playing him I'm not playing him
I think I think where you've got but now
you're going to make C for a shout back
slot in the left back slot I look at
Luke Shaw and I'm like yeah he'd
probably make it in there yeah no listen
he'll probably make it he's going to
make a CO C Mid you think of course Luke
Shaw's Luke Shaw's making it in aead of
CER and and and and for that I'd say
probably ahead of bench your world as
well I'm giving you a few here listen I
don't like your tone I don't like your
use of language what do you mean
probably bro you're giving me that I
think I think in the cold light of day
if you was honest with yourself behind
closed doors no one was going to find
out someone said to you someone said to
you right you can you can trade in let's
say Varan but but you can take Levi
coell I think You' take him I'd go
Connor Gallagher in there I'd go Kao in
there ulot could really do over K you
know because cuz you signed casemiro for
God knows how much money you love to
talk about spending you you signed
casemiro you dropped an absolute bag on
casemiro he had a massive impact last
season yeah do you know what do you know
what you're right when they bought him
in yeah they went as long as he wins us
a League Cup oh we pay 80 million for
him but as long as long as he wins us a
leag you're the one that said you'll be
comfortable with conference League mate
you know what I mean with Enzo and kaiso
in there building attack yeah at the
minute with one guy three up top you see
this guy's use of I know at the I know
he's doing if I'm going fre up top at
the minute you see what he does and I
can take him at Chelsea M I'll
go
Palmer in kungu oh my goodness here we
go and rashford not
Raheem listen let me do the real team
yeah because what you're doing is a
Madness right here yeah can I put
rashford up top you're going to have to
let me put rashford up top let
me let me put rashford up top I'm
putting Sterling and I'll put Cole
Palmer yeah that's that's not a bad
that's not a bad team a bad team I'm
fair I'm fair I'm reasonable bro no
Anthony in that team don't joke with
that one bro don't don't joke with that
Manchester United will beat Chelsea in
this upcoming match 3 2
1 woo no sorry I'm looking at the wrong
one whoa yo I'm telling you stop putting
liquor in there man
um just agree yeah agree do you know
what I'm a law of averages man and we
haven't beat you in that long that I'm
going law of averages man like if I'm
going law of averages against Man City
I'm like yeah you know stacked in their
favor but the way I see stuff yeah do
you know what I'm going strongly you
want to go strong let's go strong for
strong we're about the same but there's
one thing here there's one thing here
there's one thing here it's the Mason
Mount Derby now like that did I'm not
even going to lie it did hurt us boys
you know what I mean it did hurt us he
he you say he came for the Academy he's
a kid from Portsmouth he he's obviously
gone on to jump ship when he thought the
ship was sinking I think it holds a
strong feeling with our fan base and
that's one of the main reasons a lot of
people wouldn't say I'll just be honest
with it one of the main reasons why I'd
love to turn your boys over is just so I
can look at Rees James give Mason Mount
the little wink there he'll be back for
that game he back for that game he W
playing he w probably going to be
injured somehow some way do you know
what I mean but for us I just think we
have to beat a big team do you know what
I mean we haven't done it so far this
season we have to Wednesday it's a
Wednesday 8:15 kickoff I just think old
trafford's going to be rocking under the
lights I think that's going to be the
game where not saying we're going to
play like Barcelona or anything like
that but I think we're just going to
we're going to get the result but it's
going to be a good solid win I think you
know what I mean yeah our performances
against the big teams I know it's horses
for coures yeah but if we can keep our
heads I think we come away at three
points what's score going to
be you what you know what strongly don't
forget you know what i' I'd take a
little 2N win there we're not even going
to get a goal well you didn't against
City this is pure
disrespect have to endure here we put
four past City yeah listen you put four
past them but that was that was some
Jammy game man that was some that was a
weird game you know I mean Aral you
conceded four against City to and you
conceded against Arsen but you just
don't have respect for us that you don't
think we're going to get you have got
nowhere near the Firepower of those boys
yesterday your stats went up a little
bit but before that Nicholas Jackson had
scored more goals than your entire front
line
you you still scored more goals in your
entire front line yeah don't worry about
that we're looking at those teams there
and I'm going mate they got Firepower
they got more for us to worry about what
you boy has got and I would love Chelsea
to have it is you've got match winners
you've got Bruno Fernandez yeah that can
turn up and win you a game rashford's
not in great form this season but you
got him you can pull things out the bag
but what we've got when it's going more
often than not at the moment got a bunch
of wasteful finishers hold on why are we
talking as if you guys have got like
flipping Prime DDA drug in your team or
Diego Costa you've got Jackson who's hit
and miss he scored one of the worst
hat-tricks you will ever see in your
life at um at SP against Spurs like
literally I don't even know I don't
think he knows how he got that hatrick
Cole Palmer how about some open Play
Goals mate you know what I mean it just
pens are we just going to sit here say
ice cold Palmer forever can you get some
open Play open Play Goals I mean so you
in front of goal still are still
wasteful we're massive was we're massiv
we're massively wasteful mhm we put four
pass Spurs we put four pass man put two
you you've been coming here yeah the
whole time talking about underlying
stats and you need to look at it and you
look at that as like oh we put four pass
Spurs come on let's add the context to
the game bro you know what happened
against Spurs you know if it was even 11
okay do you know what even 10v 11 you
know you're not putting four pass SP in
the big matches so far this season you
boys have failed to show up in the big
matches so far this season we have
showed up this showed up thing that you
saying you've got three draws one win
it's not that great you're saying
it it's better it's better than what we
have done but to say you've showed up
You' think that you've won all these
games you ain't won these games three
draw yeah there we go that's the thing
though that's what your fan base are
doing your fan base are hanging on to oh
well we turn up against the big boys
never always that you're not going to
get nothing from that that's not a
that's not a trophy that's not something
to indicate progression we turn up
against the big boys but then we go
against the smaller lot and get turned
over but to play against the Chelsea
team we can still do what we're doing
right now and win against Chelsea I'm
I'm I'm 100% confident of that and I'll
be live for that as well so you'll see
you know I mean I'll call you as well
I'm going to call you live I'm going to
call you live and I'm going to say Joey
you see what I told you yeah go to that
YouTube video on live by I told you mate
you'll see John Terry was better than
Rio Ferdinand
three two
one oh you can't do that to
me can't I just stay in the middle like
you know what I mean like not sure and
all that
oh listen Rio is a close friend of mine
as well he's a he's a he's a mentor to
me but I've said it to him before you
know what I mean I've said it to him I
think John Terry was the best center
half in premier league history um I just
think his near post defending I think
both feet his leadership ability to get
goals as well just a raw
Defender his impact on Chelsea the clean
sheets the record that you guys have in
the Premier League 15 goals conceded
player of the year I just think he was
just a proper proper Center back you
know Center half and you're looking at
in that time where there was so many
good Defenders Rio vidit and PUO and P
all these guys John Terry was at the one
constant amongst all of them when you're
looking at the world team of the years
you looking at UA for team of the years
John Terry was that was that that one
you know what I mean I think it's a very
1 a 1B these are my two best center
halfes for me in the premier league
history but he was just that guy man so
hey Rio I think the things that edgit
for John Terry is if you look at the
center back Partnerships yeah everyone
talks about Terry Calo it's brilliant
but I really last at a couple of Seasons
Rio often had vidit in there with him
you know you remember he was holding
down with sylvestri and stuff of course
yeah for for for England he had JT and
there with him people forget yeah even
Woodgate was a good Defender with him at
lead you know what I mean like he had
the Partnerships there and John Terry
didn't always have that I can tell you
now like I love Gary kale but he's not
collecting multiple Premier League
winners medals without John Terry next
to him and I think also like being in
the ground yeah Stanford Bridge was loud
at them times but the loudest man in
Stanford Bridge was always JT yeah and I
always say it Rio's game is aging and
will age way better than John Terry's
way better than because we're seeing JN
Stones we're seeing obviously PK was
doing it we're seeing every seconder of
half now has to be able to play with the
ball they have to be able to drive out
and you're going to look back in time
and be like Oh Rio was doing that back
in 2000s but I have a little bit of a
more of a affiliation to a bit of them
guys that just put their head on it and
you know what I mean them proper proper
leaders so that's why I Edge John Terry
but Rio inspirational figure man at the
end of the day I think that John Terry
could pull a team a little bit more but
it's fire margin Mar why do you guys
have to do this one why do you have to
do this one I don't like this one man
honestly Chelsea will finish above
Manchester United in the Premier League
this season three two
one disagree strongly
mate put come here come here put it
right here not strongly not strongly no
way listen it's how many points are in
it at the moment as this is being shot
it's eight points yeah that's what I'm
saying that's what I'm saying so say for
example right if we go and get look
there's a lot of ifs and buts and maybe
if we go and get a result against
Brighton yeah and we go and then beat
you guys at Old Trafford all of a sudden
all of a sudden it's five points now
look at this let me just let me just
tell you this one thing right there's a
lot of good teams in the Premier League
and so far this season Man United have
done brilliant to not look great and
beat the smaller clubs when you've come
up against big teams yeah we got HED
you've been B look I think Chelsea have
got a future you guys got a future You
Got Talented players but I just think
it's too soon for you guys you know what
I mean as much as United visually on the
eye it's not good to watch it's it's
hard to watch sometimes United know how
to get results Chelsea at the on the
other hand I just don't see it in you
guys and your players to be able to go
three wins four wins five wins in a row
you know what I'm saying I just don't
see that in your squad it's the Chelsea
game it's this game yeah that I'm
looking at my ey and I'm like go put a
statement out you know what I mean go
and put a statement let's see what we
can do see this if we beat let me tell
you though if we beat you Joey you know
that's your season over right you know
that's the season over there's nothing
you're playing for for the rest of the
season we still got the domestic cups to
play for yeah and all right you might go
11 points ahead of us or whatever but
I'm telling you now like at the end of
the day yeah the cream will rise to the
top I ain't calling us the
I'm saying but what I'm saying what I'm
saying know little sugar at the bottom
the bottom of your cup when there when
there is yeah a sty of play that you're
looking at and you're thinking in fact
starter play ain't the word used there
ain't no starter play nothing's looking
good the form would suggest that
eventually that will catch up with you
but to be above Chelsea I don't think
that's that hard that's the difference I
don't think it's that hard we can still
be pretty poor and be above Chelsea cuz
I just don't see Chelsea picking up that
Runner form to capitalize on all of our
mistakes you know what I mean but to
just try and get top four or fth or six
I don't think it's that hard whereas I
think you guys are going to be lurking
around ninth eighth and there's nothing
to suggest that in my opinion that it's
just going to be a crazy upturn or form
yeah the likelihood is you ain't going
through the group stage in the Champions
League the likely yeah yeah yeah you
might you might win it you might win it
but you're going to be playing Thursday
Night Football and we're seeing at the
moment like your boys ain't looking
great at the second if they're doing
trips to a war him back or wherever else
in the Europa League it's not going to
bobe well for him so I look I've put
disagree that's fine but I never going
strongly disagree I'm never going
strongly disagree because when all said
and done when we're in that running five
games to go or so I think we'll be a lot
closer you than you're anticipating
right now we'll see then we'll see we'll
see Ronaldo Beckham you've created this
who do you think should be on the right
wing drop Ronaldo no he just doesn't
like Ronaldo wait stop stop stop stop
stop Ronaldo won the bonor at Manchester
United before he was even the best
version of Ronaldo